we we want to help people find the
videos they're interested in watching
and we start with the premise that there
are hundreds of hours of video that each
viewer would like to watch and we're
trying to figure out a way to connect
those viewers with that 100 hours of
video my name is christos Kudrow and I'm
responsible for search and discovery on
YouTube the easiest thing which actually
is not always that easy is if someone
were to search for a video right so if
you search for a video you're looking
for something particular we want to make
sure that that shows up right at the top
of the search results but even that can
sometimes be hard because searches are
ambiguous and even when the search
itself isn't ambiguous it's not always
clear which video you are looking for
because there's a lot of videos about
just about every possible imaginable
thing on YouTube but then there's
another problem which is the fact that
you may not know all the things that
there are for you to watch on YouTube
and so what if it doesn't occur to you
to search for something I used to
pole-vault
I wouldn't imagine that they are
pole-vaulting videos on YouTube but how
am I ever gonna find them if I don't
bother to search for them well somehow
we've got to connect you with those
videos as well why do you feel compelled
to connect me with a video I wasn't
looking for is that a business thing for
you because you want to keep people
engaged with your product we know that
creators uploaded these videos and there
are viewers interested in these videos
and we feel like it's our job to make
that connection if we're not gonna help
make that connection why should the
creator's bother to upload those videos
I mean that's one thing that I'd like to
make clear is that our success depends
on helping the creators find their
viewers the simplest thing is that if we
see you watch one of a certain kind of
video then we know that other people who
watch that video in the past went on to
watch this other video and so it's quite
natural that if we see you've watched
this first one that we might think that
you watch that you'd want to watch that
other one too that's mostly a matter of
just accounting more than anything else
it's just keeping track of which videos
get watched together and so so that's
the simplest way we do it if you take
that to a more sophisticated level let's
you watched a few videos about Lionel
Messi and you watched a few others about
Cristiano Ronaldo I think maybe you
might be interested in soccer so we
might recommend to a video that isn't
just about Lionel Messi or Cristiano
Ronaldo but some other soccer team
that's playing because you've
demonstrated some evidence in a in the
broader subject another way that we
might find to recommend things to you
are videos that are popular in your
geographical area so as you can imagine
Bollywood is very popular in India it's
also popular among people outside of
India but in order to recommend it to
those people we would want to see some
evidence that they are interested in
Bollywood
some of this is quite obvious but also
some of it's quite crude you know
geographic areas you're an engineer you
like Bollywood how sophisticated are you
guys getting with this now
I think the sophistication comes from
figuring out what's important about the
video that indicates your interest in it
so for instance you might have watched
some soccer videos but it was because
those were the most amazing goals and
you're not really that interested in
soccer but you're really interested in
just amazing sporting things or you
might have watched those videos because
they were from a team that you happen to
follow because that's an area of the
world that you're from and so the
sophistication comes in separate
separating those two kinds of
associations or even in a more crude
level in figuring out what's important
about that video that that would make us
want to suggest it to some other person
do you have to understand people or are
you just like just number crunchers
the human understanding part is where we
take our intuition for what sorts of
changes we might try next you could
imagine that there's a lot of things
that we could try and we can't do all of
them at once and so we have to use some
intuition about which sort of things we
expect might be more or less successful
than than other things first of all we
look at experiments a lot
so we're running a b tests on youtube
itself we also do qualitative research
so we invite people to come and sit with
us and watch them use YouTube and ask
them the kinds of things they're
interested in and ask them that they
would expect to find that on YouTube if
they've ever seen that on YouTube you
know how would they go about finding it
on YouTube and and we use those sorts of
qualitative analyses to try to guide our
intuition for what sort of experiments
we run but it all comes back to making
these broad changes and then
experimenting with them and what's
important about that is because each
change that we make because we've done
experiments we can be sure that it's
improved the situation now it may not
have improved it uniformly across the
board but overall it's it's been an
improvement what is the biggest grunt
and who does it come from the biggest
gripe is you have a billion videos and I
can't find anything good to watch and
that's that's basically solving that
problem for the viewers is our mission
of course people people often say as
well that they can't find the video that
they're looking for and you know there's
just many many different queries and
ways that people go about looking for
things and you know we we keep working
on them one after another until we
figure them out well it's easy for our
systems to get confused by in my case
I'll give you an example a friend sends
me a video about a ski race from in
Southern California and it's because my
cousin has a boat entered in this ski
race i watch his video and it's actually
quite long and then i watch a couple
more videos but i'm not really very
interested in this sort of thing the
next day I come back and there's more
videos waiting for me about this ski
race I think okay well that's fine but
two weeks later I come back and there's
yet more videos about this case
and I think to myself I'm sorry that I
watched those videos about the ski race
you got me I did but but what do I have
to do to get you to realize that I'm not
gonna watch any more of these well I
mean it's easy for our systems to become
confused about the fact that you happen
to have watched it at one time but
you're not really interested in it very
much as opposed to well you you watched
a little bit less of something but
that's something that you really like to
see more of and so we we don't have the
information we have to go on is what you
and other people have watched in the
past and so using all of that and by the
way it's only you and a billion other
people using all of that and trying to
make sense of it is is what becomes hard
do you build a random chance element
into it I'm not saying like here's a
completely random video but does it
allow for a degree of this is another
baseball video but it's bit of a wild
card or is then is that not because I
guess I'm touching on making it a
modulus we do work on trying to increase
diversity and the challenge there is
that we have an intuitive belief that
increasing diversity will lead to the
opportunity to get even even more
viewership in the future but every time
we try to increase diversity we tend to
reduce the amount of viewership we have
in the short term well I think it's
because we haven't quite gotten it right
yet and so um you know until we can
until we can recommend sort of
unexpected things that are almost always
right people will just go away they
won't see as much of what they were
looking for or what they expected and
they go away
and so I guess it's a quite a high bar
to add some diverse things there and so
even though we have this intuition and
our experiments tend to make us more
conservative with it that's the way that
we want to go about trying to add I
would
call it that I would say that are the
naive approach to trying to increase
diversity would be to add a random
element and I can assure you that that's
not going to work because you give up
too much viewership in the short term
and so what we've learned is that random
isn't good enough and we need to make it
so that we're almost always right when
we add some diverse and unexpected
element my Holy Grail is to come to
YouTube and have it find the hundreds of
hours of videos that I can't stop
watching because those are the ones that
I'm interested in and I think the
important point about this is that it's
not going to be the same as yours or
someone else's and you might think well
how different can it be I mean you know
I and all my friends seem to like all
the same videos that we see on YouTube
and while that may be true think about
you know think about some children that
you know and they're you know their
favorite videos probably won't will be
different than yours and then think
about your parents their videos would
probably be different than yours and now
think about the people in another
country and how different what they're
interested in watching is from yours
like we need to solve this problem for
everybody across the across the world
and that is really the holy grail is how
do we connect each one of those people
with their diverse interests with the
videos they're looking for and want to
watch I think the most important thing
is that we are very interested in
helping the creator's connect to their
fans and helping them increase their
viewership because that's entirely in
our interests and so that's the thing
that I want to make sure people
understand is that when we make changes
to things it's because we absolutely
believe that it improves the ability for
creators to be successful
and everybody was going to click on that
one and when someone's writing code the
video guy they need to put the logic in
the code that says you know where you
should stop